Please welcome today's Drew-Gooder, Joe Caramagna.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Okay, I hear you're known
for being like a doughnut connoisseur.
I can't even believe this is in front of me right now.
(Joe laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yeah, I have a little bit of a reputation, I guess.
I make comic books and graphic novels for a living.
So I travel to a lot of different comic conventions
across the country.
And the joke is that I tell people to bring me doughnuts
or other sweet treats and I'll pay them back in comics,
and people do.
They bring me doughnuts all the time.
(audience laughs)
And everywhere I travel, I always,
I seek out the local doughnut shop, and I sample it
and test them out and everything.
And I end up keeping in touch
with a lot of the shops on social media.
And one of the shops is Broad Street Dough Co.,
which is in Oakhurst, New Jersey.
They also have a store in Freehold.
And they actually gave me the opportunity
to create my own doughnut that I call the Joenut. (laughs)
The Joenut!
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
That's so perfect!
(Joe laughs)
How did you start matriculating
and associating doughnuts with like philanthropy?
How did that happen?
Well, pre-pandemic, I used to raise money
for the Ronald McDonald House Charities
at different comic conventions.
And I would put a little change box
in front of me at the meet-and-greet table,
and people would come by and draw up in like $5, $10,
and I would give them signed comics in return.
But unfortunately, because of the pandemic,
a lot of live events kinda went away for a while.
And Krispy Kreme announced their promotion
that they would give away one free glazed doughnut
every day if you show your vaccination card.
That's right.
We did a story about that on the news,
yeah.
Right.
And I take a walk every morning
as part of my just daily routine.
So there's a store that happens to be a mile away
from my house.
So I turn that into my daily walk
and started going every day.
And (laughs) I would post pictures of me
with my free doughnut on social media,
and put a little silly caption or something,
and try to encourage people to get vaccinated.
And people seem to enjoy it.
And I decided that I would do something
and kinda tie in my love
for the Ronald McDonald House Charities,
and I decided to give $1 for every free doughnut I got.
The money I'm saving on doughnuts,
I'll donate to the Ronald McDonald House
in Winston-Salem, North Carolina.
And this is personal for you, the Ronald McDonald House.
Will you tell us why?
Sure.
When my oldest daughter, Julia, was born,
she had some life-threatening complications,
and she had to be transported to another hospital,
a children's hospital.
And that's pretty much where my wife
and I lived for the first month of her life.
But I remember feeling very lucky, actually, because my wife
and I actually lived somewhat close to the hospital,
so we were able to go back and forth to home.
And we saw some families there
that didn't have that situation,
and they had to sleep in waiting rooms
and pushing like two chairs together to make a bed.
And years later, I found out what it is
that the Ronald McDonald House actually does.
And that's provide a home away from home
for families with seriously ill children
that have to travel a long distance to go to the hospital.
And as soon as I found that out,
I knew that that's a mission that I wanted to be a part of
because I actually saw the need for it.
Oh, you're so...
I love this so much. You're such a good person.
I'm-
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
So glad that you're doing this.
Thank you.
I'm sorry that you had to go through that
and so grateful that you were able to turn your pain
and fear into this awareness and take care of others.
Our friends at The Make Sense Foundation,
founded by SeneGence, a female-owned cosmetic brand,
heard what you were doing and they wanted to help.
So they're donating $10,000
to the Ronald McDonald House
(audience cheers)
of the Piedmont Triad
in your honor, Joe.
Wow, thank you so much.
That's amazing. Thank you.
There's also, we know that you've walked
over 400 miles for a good cause,
and we wanted to give you something to keep you on your feet
so you could keep doing all the good things you're doing.
And truMedic is gonna give you a massage chair.
Oh, my gosh.
Believe me,
(audience applauds)
(Joe laughs)
we have one upstairs,
and the entire crew uses it.
Wow.
We all take turns.
Oh, wow.
So maybe you can kick back, eat a doughnut,
and realize that there are thousands and thousands
and thousands of dollars going to Ronald McDonald House
in your honor.
Thank you so much.
That's very kind.
I'm gonna have to fight my kids
for use of that massage chair.
(audience applauds)
(Joe laughs)
If you saw us here, we're all fighting each other for it.
It works like a charm.
Joe, thank you for doing what you're doing
and bringing awareness to the Ronald McDonald House,
really and truly.
Thank you so much for giving me the opportunity
to talk about it.
'Cause the first time I ever heard
about the Ronald McDonald House was on a radio show,
so I know how this can lead to good things,
just putting it out there for people to see.
Let's hope that it does.
Let's try.
I hope so.
If you go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
you'll learn all about how to donate
to the Ronald McDonald House and support that.
And thank you, Joe.
(upbeat pop music)